so president trump has coveted that's
all i got
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn stand up for your digital
rights visit expressvpn.com
well there it was sitting like chekhov's
gun at the uh
at the top of the mantle piece and it
was only a matter of time until
chekhov's gun was fired
of course in just one second we'll get
to all of that first
let us talk about the fact that you
require better
better cell phone coverage i mean the
same cell phone coverage that you would
get with any other
major company but the fact is that you
don't need to be spending all that much
money on your cell phone coverage you
are probably spending way too much money
on your cell phone coverage in fact well
that is why you should be checking out
pure talk usa
look at your cell phone bill where it
shows data usage the average person who
switches to pure talk is using less than
four gigs of data a month
the big carriers are charging you for
unlimited data which is like paying for
an entire row on an airplane but you
only need
one seat that's how pure talk saves the
average person over 400
a year on their wireless service
unlimited talk text two gigs of data all
for just twenty dollars a month
and if you go over on data usage they
won't charge you for it folks switching
to peer talk it's the easiest decision
you will make today you can save all
sorts of money
and all sorts of money means saving all
sorts of time as well grab your mobile
phones i'll pound 250 say ben
shapiro when you do you'll save 50 off
your first month tile pound 2 5 0 say
keyword ben shapiro
pure talk is indeed simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
dial pound at 250
and say keyword ben shapiro again that
is pound
250 and say keyword ben shapiro okay so
obviously the big news of the day of the
month of the year is that president
trump
has been confirmed to have cove but he
tweeted this news out
last night he tweeted out that he and
the
and the first lady have both been tested
positive for comedy he tweeted tonight
flotus and i tested positive for kelvin
19 we'll begin our quarantine
and recovery process immediately we will
get through this together
and you know naturally you all the same
people
on twitter with the blue check marks you
would expect have been just about as
nasty as you would expect
some people have not been some people
have been pretty classy about it we'll
get to that in a second
but the the white house doctor did
release a note
on this the white house doctor
acknowledging that the president has
come
come down with covet here is the letter
it says i release the following
information with the permission of
president trump and first lady melania
trump
this evening i received confirmation
that both president trump and first lady
melania trump have tested positive force
coveted to virus the president first
lady are both well at this time they
plan to remain at home within the white
house during their convalescence
the white house medical team and i will
maintain a vigilant watch i appreciate
the support provided by some of our
country's greatest medical professions
and institutions rest assured i expect
the president to continue carrying out
his duties without disruption while
recovering i will keep you updated on
any
future developments now obviously we
don't know the direction that covet 19
is going to take the president is 74
years old
he is overweight which is a complicating
factor it is a pre-existing condition it
is an underlying condition
that can exacerbate the effect of covet
19 so far it has been
reported that the president of the
united states has a
mild case or at least his symptoms are
mild
we'll see how this plays forward
honestly i think from from political
point of view obviously politics comes
second so
our prayers go out to the trump family
just so they go out to any family that
is suffering with
covet 19 which can in fact be a very
serious
disease politically speaking this throws
a wrench into
a lot of what's going on because we have
a debate that is scheduled for about two
weeks from now presumably if the
president
goes through the process and then he
quarantines for 14 days he will get
out i believe literally the day of the
debate to do that debate so it throws a
wrench
into that it obviously throws a wrench
into his campaign schedule he's not
going to be going out and doing public
events for quite a while because he's
supposed to according to the cdc
quarantined for 10 to 14 days we have to
see of course
the the vector that the disease is going
to take which direction the disease
is going to take here the political
fallout here is pretty obvious
for trump and the political fallout as
we'll see is
largely surrounding the severity of the
disease
if trump recovers from the disease
quickly if it turns out that this virus
is something that doesn't affect him
really badly and that
in four or five days he's basically back
to normal he has a mild case
then he's going to be able to go out and
he's going to say listen i know that
this thing
definitely affects some people truly
terribly and we have to protect those
people we have to make sure they get all
the care that they could possibly need
but the truth is that the vast majority
of cases tend to be rather mild and that
is true i mean statistically it is true
the vast majority of these cases tend to
be rather mild virtually
everyone below the age of 50 who gets
this thing recovers of it the death
rates on this thing
are extraordinarily striated by age if
you're under the age of 20
then your likelihood of dying from covet
19 is something like
two in ten thousand if you are above the
age of
70 then your chances of dying of this
thing are something like five percent
which is a lot higher obviously and
trump is in that
later that latter cohort so if he
recovers quickly and if he recovers
easily he's going to be able to
say with a certain amount of credibility
that it is important to recognize that
this disease does not affect everybody
equivalently
that many of these cases are mild and
it's important to keep that in mind when
we are talking
about recovery and the campaign probably
moves on obviously if it's much more
severe
then we don't just have a political
issue on our hands we have like an
actual human life issue
on our hands now it turns out a lot of
people
have been infected inside the white
house apparently this thing started with
hope hicks
is the current supposition hope picks of
course is a top
aide to the president of the united
states other people who have tested
positive
at this point include ronald mcdaniel
which is a guest a little bit earlier on
the
show this week ronald mcdaniel the
chairwoman of the rnc according to the
new york times has tested positive for
covet and is experiencing mild symptoms
according to several people briefed on
the situation
ms mcdaniel is the latest person in
frequent contact with trump to test
positive
for the virus apparently she received
her diagnosis on wednesday and after a
crowded donor event in march at
mar-a-lago the president's private club
in florida ms mcdaniel felt ill but she
tested negative
way back then of course trump is not the
first world leader to be infected prime
minister boris johnson and britain had a
very serious case i mean he was actually
hospitalized
president yerba bolsonaro of brazil
tested positive
as well bolsonaro's case was was much
milder than
johnson's case both of those men are
significantly younger than trump
he is older and probably at higher risk
just on a basic medical level
than either of those people it is true
that
a lot of people today are pointing out
you know trump's personal behavior and
we'll get into that in just a second
and they're pointing out that earlier
this week he seemed lethargic and that
you know he maybe should have taken
precautions at that point why wasn't
wasn't tested at that point
mike pence for for what it's worth mike
pence and the first and the second lady
karen pence have both tested negative
for the virus
at this point and it is also true that
a lot of people get this thing and a lot
of people recover from this thing and a
lot of people get it under different
circumstances for example
justin trudeau's wife had this thing and
so
there's this sort of belief out there
this talismanic belief that if you do
all of the right things or if
what's what's even more bizarre if you
say all of the right things that you're
immune from the disease
and one of the things that's very
frustrating is people who watch this in
an attempt to be objective in any real
way about this is that there are certain
things you can do to minimize the
chances that you're going to get it
there's no guarantee you're not going to
get it because we're all living life
you're going to run into contact with
people n95 masks
may provide you a significant barrier
they may provide you
real protection but cloth masks don't
provide the same protection the original
idea of cloth masks was that mainly
you're preventing
other people from getting it not that it
prevents you from getting it there was a
point
a month ago where anthony fauci was
suggesting this thing is transmissible
via the eyes
so he was suggesting that people
actually wear goggles if they could so
there's no guarantee
that you're not going to get it there
are things you can do to minimize it
we'll talk about whether trump has done
those things
but there's this belief on the left as
we'll see that even more than any of
that
if you virtue signal about the virus
this acts as some sort of protection so
trump's great sin here was not even his
personal behavior
it was the stuff that trump said if
trump had just said i'm super serious
about it over and over and over it would
have been fine or if trump presumably
had protested
like a black lives matter rally he
wouldn't have gotten it or if he did get
it then it would have been worth it
because he would have been protesting
racism one of the big problems with this
entire debacle since march
is that where we should have been
following the science and being measured
in our language
about what works and what doesn't where
we should have pointed out
that risk factors vary by age where we
should have pointed out
that certain types of mass are better
than other types of mass and we should
have stopped this sort of
virtue signaling about how if you wear a
mask but it's below your nose that's
better than not wearing a mask at all or
something
or that if you wear a neck gator that's
i mean the cdc has said by the way a
neck gator is actually worse than
nothing
a neck gaitor actually helps aerosolize
your spin like if you sneeze into a
negator it actually
blows it through the thing like a sieve
and then it just kind of
makes it go further it actually aerosols
it wider okay so
my big problem here is is twofold one i
think there's some legit criticisms to
be made of how trump
has personally in terms of his uh
attitude and what he's conveyed to other
people and his personal behavior has
handled coven
i also think that the media have set up
these bizarre standards where
you're immune to the disease if you are
protesting for racial justice
where if you run around and virtue
signal about wearing a mask 100 feet
from
other people this somehow makes you
immune to the disease
when it really has nothing to do with
any of that there's this sort of
talismanic worship of particular modes
of discussing
this disease that if you take it super
seriously then at least you're protected
from the backlash of the mockery if you
do get it
and again that is completely separated
from the public policy discussion
it's completely separated from a
rational scientific discussion of these
issues
so for example i've said on the show
many times that if you're my age if
you're 36 and you're
thank god healthy i'm 36 and i'm healthy
i don't have any underlying conditions
if i get this thing i'm not particularly
afraid of getting this thing because i'm
and i have no underlying conditions and
then i said it is also possible that i
could die of this thing if i get it
because it is possible that anybody
could die of this thing
if they get it although the chances are
extremely unlikely
now because i've said the former part
which is that statistically speaking i'm
extremely unlikely to die of this
disease
if god forbid something were to happen
to me then the media would jump on that
and suggest that i was taking it lightly
even though i specifically say
at the end of that sentence that it
could happen to me it's just very
unlikely that it's going to happen
to me people do not seem to understand
how statistics work in any real way so
if you say things like
trump has said before that not very many
people are dying of this thing
relative to the percentage of the
population at this point depending on
age
that may be statistically true it can
also be
it can also be insensitive but people
will use that as an example of trump not
taking the thing seriously as opposed to
is what he is saying actually true
right he said earlier that if you're
young and you get it you really are not
at high risk that happens to be a true
statement that's not an example of him
not taking it seriously and you saying
that you are at high risk if you're five
as opposed to if you're 80 is actually
being statistically
irresponsible with the information but
morally irresponsible right this is sort
of the divide that has happened
is that if you discuss this thing in a
statistically responsible way then you
are charged with being morally
irresponsible it's the aoc version of
reality
and if you say things that are
statistically irresponsible if you say
well yes it's true that older people get
it but if you're young you definitely
could die of it without any sort
of examination of the base rates or the
actual death rates the infection
fatality rates then you are considered
good and so if something happens to you
then we can say well she took it
seriously right that was a good person
it's become a moral battle as much as it
has been a scientific battle
we'll get to more of that in just one
second and we will trace president
trump's actions over the past
few days members of the media are
starting to go nuts because now they are
saying
that kaylee mcenany was exposed to this
thing back on wednesday did she know
that she was exposed to this thing back
on wednesday when she did
her presser yes i'm sure kaylee
mcinerney walked into the press
room and and just deliberately blew cove
it all over everybody i'm sure that she
hates the press that much kaylee
mackinney i mean
we're getting a little bit over our skis
here guys we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you
actually don't want to be going to the
auto body
store right now auto parts store you
don't want to do it in fact why would
you ever want to do it you're going to
be overpaying
for the same auto parts that you would
get if you just went online just like
everything else
shopping online it is competitive it is
faster it is easier
is less it is less expensive go check
out rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same part
the rockauto.com catalog it's unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selections they've
got amazingly
low prices and all the parts your car
will ever need rockauto.com head on over
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for the car truck and
write shapiro
in there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent you again write
my name shapiro in there how did you
hear about us boxing you know we sent
you that helps our advertisers and it
helps the show
we really do appreciate it check out
rockauto.com
okay so there are now questions as to
how many people trump has come
into contact with so obviously he
debated
joe biden a little bit earlier this week
they were socially distanced in that
debate they look like they're probably
10 feet apart now it was a very loud
debate
right i assume that joe biden is being
continuously tested as well he should be
i mean joe biden is 78 years old and he
does not look like he is in
significantly wonderful health so i'm
hoping you know it's truly
that joe biden is being regularly tested
by the way i hope that everybody who's
suspicious that they might have symptoms
is regularly tested or that if you're
going to be in contact with somebody who
is vulnerable that you're regularly
tested
i've been you know i would say pretty
meticulous on this sort of stuff
i think since march i've been tested
some five times knowing that i was going
to be in contact
with somebody else i've had an antibody
test twice right i
i believe that testing is a very very
good thing and i'm i'm
hopeful and i'm sure that joe biden has
been tested
for this thing but the president was in
contact with joe biden a little bit
earlier
this week apparently it was evident
earlier this week that he was feeling
poorly
like as of tuesday wednesday it became
pretty clear
that he was a little bit under the
weather according to the uk daily mail
fears that the president may have
contracted the virus were raised after
it was revealed that hope hicks had
traveled on both marine won the
presidential helicopter and on air force
one in the last seven days which
transported the president and his staff
to the presidential debate on tuesday
and other campaign rallies around the
country hicks also traveled with the
president to a rally in pennsylvania
last saturday where she's seen
masculists and clapping to the village
people's ymca
she's also been pictured with jared
kushner and other senior white house
staff
in that time now jared and ivanka have
both tested negative for covet so that
means the dependencies have tested
negative it means the kushners have
tested negative
trump and his wife have tested positive
ronald mcdaniel has tested positive
that's what we know
thus far so here is sort of the timeline
september 26th
the the trump family flew to
pennsylvania where they did
uh a bit of an event uh the the
the president did meet with uh judge amy
coney barrett a little bit earlier this
week
again right now the date is october 2nd
so the chances that he conveyed it to
amy coney bear are extremely extremely
low i'm sure she's been tested as well
democrats are trying to claim by the way
that this should be a case for
pushing off the confirmation for amy
coney bear amy coney barrett doesn't
have it
and by the way even if she did that
would not be a case for pushing off the
confirmation so long as she is capable
of zooming into the session i mean they
literally had james comey testify
in front of the senate by zoom so amy
coney barrett could do exactly
the same thing on september 28th
president trump gave an update on covet
19 testing strategy with the vp before
meeting with white house trade advisor
peter navarro to inspect a new electric
pickup truck
on september 29th he went to ohio
before boarding marine one the president
was pictured waving to crowds of
supporters during the debate they stood
at trump and biden over six feet apart
but they did not
wear masks obviously on september 30th
which is just a couple of days ago at
which point it is probable
that trump had contracted kovid right
because hopex was confirmed on wednesday
ivanka trump shared a picture of her
instagram account
with her and her dad on air force one
later that day the president traveled
again with hope hicks to another
campaign rally this time in duluth
minnesota
he was seen in front of a large crowd of
people many of whom were not wearing
masks he threw a hat
into the crowd on october 1st before
trump would later announce his positive
test results ivanka was pictured
visiting
charlotte north carolina mingling with
members of the public and trump attended
a fundraiser in new jersey where he
participated in a round table with a
bunch of supporters apparently many of
whom are now very nervous because
he was in close proximity to them all of
this of course
raises questions about the president's
personal behavior in the aftermath of
hope hicks doing this should he have
been acting this way
you know should he have been in close
contact with people given the fact that
he is 74 years old
and again overweight you know if i were
advising the president i would have told
him a long time ago that he should be
massed up in close proximity to people
i've told my old parents they should be
and my parents are 64 not 74.
i tend to be on the cautious side now
trump is fully capable of choosing what
he wants to choose
there's certain risks that come
attendance on that it's a free country
that does carry questions about the
messaging that he's been pushing to the
american public about being cautious
and this is what the media have been
jumping on full scale so in a second
we're gonna get to
some of the classy leftists and then
we'll get to some of the not class he
left us and then we'll get into the
broader debate
over trump and how this affects the
election and everything that has to do
with trump's promulgation of messaging
on kovid we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that you want
to know who's at your door you just do
i mean very often when people want to
rob your house they'll actually ring the
doorbell see if you are home and then if
you're not home they'll go rob the house
so if somebody rings your doorbell and
you pick it up now they're not going to
rob your house also you can tell that
somebody is dropping off
a package you can tell if you got
friends over you don't have to be home
and you can tell what's going on on your
property from literally thousands of
miles away this is why i love
ring.com ring has everything you need to
protect your home cn speak to whomever
is at your door from anywhere with video
doorbells keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install
yourself and i've been using ring on my
own property for years
we've experienced significant security
threats in that time and ring has been
indispensable in making sure that my
wife felt safe
and also that we could alert people in
case god forbid something went wrong
also it's allowed me to keep track of my
uh my wild
children who are little suicide machines
so i can see them running around the
property and make sure that they're not
doing something that will require
immediate medical
assistance got a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com
ben it comes with the ring video
doorbell three and the time pro it is
the perfect way to start your ring
experience plus free two-day shipping go
to ring.com again that is ring.com
ben okay so as i say some people have
been classy about this some people have
not rachel maddow was classy about this
she tweeted out
god bless the president and the first
lady if you if you pray please pray for
their speedy and complete recovery and
for everyone infected everywhere
this virus is horrific and merciless no
one will wish its wrath on anyone we
must get it spread under control
enough okay that that is a classy
response joe biden for his part
sense of classy response he tweeted out
jill and i send our thoughts to
president trump and first lady melania
trump for a swift recovery will continue
to pray for the health and safety of the
president and his family this is the
proper response then there are the
people the blue checks on twitter who
are giving
i would say rather improper responses so
just one example
the former national spokeswoman for
hillary clinton's 2016 campaign and
former obama white house staffer her
name is zara rahim
she tweeted out literally it's been
against my moral identity to tweet this
for the past four years but i hope he
dies
doesn't seem that nice linda sarsour who
is a delight she tweeted out
seems like someone don't want to go back
to the debate stage so apparently he's
now faking covet in order to avoid
debating donald trump yes i'm sure
that that is what's happening george
conway
always classy he tweeted out he failed
to protect the country he couldn't even
protect himself yes that that's
delightful
just wonderful comedian hari kondabalu
tweeted out my response to people
telling me to take the higher ground
hashtag trump has coveted and it's a
picture of a man
flipping somebody off miley rivera a
sports writer for espn said there is a
god
john fugal saying alleged comedian and
uh an
originator of the term being foogle sang
which means somebody tells a really
stupid joke about you but then thinks
they're really funny
i coined that term by the way john fugal
saying tweeted out guys great news i
just invested my entire life savings and
hydroxychloroquine
trump has covered oh funny funny funny
stuff okay so some people were classy
some people were not
i think overall some of the top figures
were classy the media
less classy the media less classy
because the media are interested in the
narrative above
all now again there are a couple things
that the media ought to mention at the
top
one is you can take as many protective
measures as you want there's no
guarantee you're not going to get
covered
that is just a reality of the situation
that doesn't mean that you should ignore
those protective measures if you don't
want to get coped
it does mean that pretending that you
have the
all sure knowledge of when people are
going to get coveted and how they get
coveted
then i guess you know more than
virtually all the medical professionals
because we are still trying to figure
out who the super spreaders are how they
spread
under what conditions this thing spreads
we're seven months in and we still don't
know
the answers to a lot of these questions
but apparently don lemon does so cnn's
done lemon who is just the worst i mean
he he is
i was for a while wondering whether don
lemon was the dumbest man on tv or for
or was chris cuomo it's pretty obviously
don lemon at this point so don lemon
on cnn was uh was essentially
ripping on trump because he says that
trump had called kova to hoax trump
never
called kovat a hoax he did not that
isn't that that's a lie it's just not
true
trump said that the democratic response
to the virus
which was that the white house was
totally inept and all he said
the media playing up the white house's
bad response was a hoax
okay and you may agree with that or you
may disagree with that but he never said
the virus itself is a hoax i mean go
back and look at the actual comments
this has been fact checked by virtually
every fact checker it is not true
that trump called kova 19 a hoax but don
lemon your objective journalism
expert over at cnn he says that the
president the hoax got him the hoax got
him
is this a moment of reckoning for the
president
and this administration for all of the
all of the pretending or looking the
other way
and trying to convince people otherwise
of the science for whatever reason
whether
whether it was for to make sure that he
was reelected
to make sure that he had high standing
with the public
or just um to for whatever reason for
because of the economy
is this now a moment of reckoning that
yes this is real it is not a hoax
okay no one said it was a hoax this is a
moment of reckoning so
again the media's a take here is that if
trump had just said the right things
if trump had been super strict in what
he said then he wouldn't have gotten
covet
and this is part and parcel of the
media's general take on covet which is
that the only thing that you can do and
receive the media's
world wisdom and and all of their and
all of their
sycophantic love is just shut everything
down right this is this part and parcel
of the entire lockdown debate
because their view is that if you lock
everything down then you can be blamed
for nothing whereas if you say that
certain things should be open or if you
talk about the gradated risks
of covet if you talk about the actual
fact regarding mask wearing which is
that
the evidence is somewhat mixed given the
fact that in northern europe they don't
mask up in southern europe they do mask
up and there are differential rates
that tend to benefit northern europe or
the fact that you actually have to have
a class and how to wear a mask properly
or the different types of masks
serve differently right if you mention
any of that then they will say that you
are down playing the effectiveness of
mass because it's proven that if you
wear a mask it's better than if you
don't wear a mask
okay well that is true if everyone
properly wears the mask
but it is not true if they're people who
are improperly wearing the mask or if
they're wearing it under their nose
right if you mention any of that stuff
they say you are down playing mask
wearing
because we have now conflated and this
is a deeper conversation we have now
conflated in american politics
people saying true things and people
inferring things
from those true things so if i say a
fact and somebody infers something that
i don't agree with from that fact
the media will hold me responsible for
the inference
if i say something that is factual and
somebody takes it too far
the media will then try to hold me
responsible for the inference by the way
this only works one way if you're on the
right this is true
right if somebody on the right says
something and it happens to be a true
thing
and then somebody takes that true thing
and spins it completely out of
proportion and does something crazy
based on it they will hold the right
responsible for it on the left
this is never true on the left you can
say virtually anything you want whether
it's true or false and the media will
never hold you responsible for the
baseline facts
factual truth or falsity of the
situation but this is one of the things
that's happened with the entire cova
discussion
so if ron desantis in florida says here
by age and by pre-existing condition is
the death rate uncovered they'll say ah
look at that
people are going to take that and now
they're going to be irresponsible and
that's ron desantis fault
why is that ronda census fault do we
have to assume that people don't have
agency i mean the basic bottom line
leftist view is that people very often
do not have agency
their view is that only the government
can mandate things
but this ties into how people are
responding to
all of this okay because it turns out
that
trump's attitude and what he says are
very often in conflict
people have drawn messages from trump
that trump himself has not necessarily
said
so take a perfect example so over the
we'll take a perfect example from the
debate we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that you need to protect your
online data you do
well i'll tell you one of the ways you
can protect your online data is to get
pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus designed to stop modern
threats like ransomware
independent testing from a v test they
just named pcmatic top performer in the
cyber security industry giving it the
best performance award for 2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
and pcmatic will block those annoying
and malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing
makes your computers faster and more
reliable even after years
of use one of the things that's so
beautiful about pcmatic is that it
protects virtually all devices windows
computers including xp vista windows 7 8
and 10 windows servers
it protects macs macbooks android phones
and tablets and it's just 50 bucks for
five devices for one year with a full
30 day money back guarantee they're
constantly evolving they're constantly
fighting back against the malware threat
to your computer there's nothing worse
than male or hitting your computer it's
happening it's just terrible
pcmatic puts a stop to all of that to
access their special offer 50 bucks for
five devices for one year
a full 30 day money back guarantee and
right now if you act pcmatic has offered
my listeners a free month of security
protection
with the purchase of an annual license
just head on over to pcmatic.com again
to get that world-class security with
that special deal keeps your computer
running great go to pcmatic.com
that is pcmatic.com ben okay so
let's talk for a second about some of
the stuff that trump has said because
very often trump will say something
that is fairly factual but said in a
particular manner and so the media focus
in on the matter rather than on the fact
of what he is saying perfect example
yesterday kyle griffin was a senior
producer for msnbc's the last word
he tweeted out trump doesn't wear masks
trump doesn't promote social distancing
white house staff don't wear masks white
house staff don't social distance
trump holds large rallies and events
where no one wears masks and no on
social distances
okay so there's truth to some of this
and there's untruth to some of this so
trump
sometimes does wear masks trump does at
his rally social distance from the other
people
in the crowd i don't know what it means
to promote social distancing right he's
literally said in speeches and
from the white house rostrum at the
press conferences that people should
socially distance and he has said that
you should wear a mask
one of the problems for trump is that he
has said so many things on this issue
that people can sort of pick and choose
from the tree i'm not going to pretend
that trump has been consistent in his
messaging because he has not
and it's that inconsistency in messaging
that politically is coming back to bite
him right now
the fact is that if trump had said
listen if you're under the age of 50
the threat to you is not particularly
grave go out and do what you want
and then he had held by that he said but
listen i'm 74 i'm wearing a mask i'm
socially distancing
then you live by that but he's sort of
been on all sides of the issue
so you know the wishy washiness of it is
kind of a problem but it
is not true that trump never wears masks
it's not true that trump never promotes
social distancing
as far as white house staff not wearing
masks some white house staff do wear
masks other white house staff do not
wear masks
as far as white house staff not socially
distancing some white house have to some
white house staff do not i know many
members of the white house
staff and as far as him holding large
rallies and events where no one wears
masks and no one socially distances
again the media don't really have that
much of a leg to stand on here given the
fact
that they have been promoting huge
open-air rallies with people not masked
dancing around like idiots
in the streets for months at a time
right so
there's a bit of hypocrisy there as well
okay so
perfect example of the difference
between trump saying something that
happens to be
kind of factually true and the
implication taken away from it and trump
being blamed for the implication
i think sometimes that's fair i think
sometimes it's not right trump
attitudinally
doesn't like the mask you can tell right
attitudinally trump is not a fan of the
masking
he's been very wishy-washy about it from
the beginning
does that mean that he has overtly told
people don't wear masks no he has not
said that
but we'll take an example so during the
debate here was trump
mocking biden for wearing a mask
uselessly now people are going to ignore
the last word that sends uselessly
he was he was asked do you wear masks
why aren't you pushing masks and heroes
trump's response to the debate just a
couple of nights ago
are you questioning no i think they'll
be asking okay
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put a
mask on it
you know when i think i need it tonight
as an example everybody's had a test
and you've had social distancing and all
of the things that you have to but
i wear masks when needed when needed i
wear a mask
okay let me ask i don't have to i don't
wear mess like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
okay people took this clip and they said
okay that's trump not promoting
masculine
okay but if you actually read the text
of it he's saying joe biden is over here
not wearing the mask like 200 feet away
he's like 200 feet away from people and
wearing a mask that's very silly
okay it is silly to wear a mask if
you're 200 feet away from other people
there's no reason to do that
but people took that as trump is
dismissive of masks overall and this
does go to
the power that i think that many members
of the media and many members of the
left think
that political figures have over
people's lives so people on the left
believe that the reason that joe biden
should wear a mask is because he needs
to model to the american public
you need to wear a mask in all
circumstances and that if he is wearing
a mask 200 feet away from everybody else
then you should certainly be wearing a
mask in close quarters whereas trump
doesn't tend to model that behavior very
well there's a lot of pictures of him
not wearing a mask
when he is fairly close with other
people and he's not modeling the
behavior
and the case up until now has been well
he's not modeling behavior because he's
one of the most tested
people on earth he's surrounded by a
bubble and
you know that that is that's the way it
works i mean people around him are being
regularly tested
presumably well now that he's gotten
that that's come to bite him
in the butt for sure but if you watch
that clip he's not saying never wear a
mask
the media take that as he's saying never
wear a mask
and this has become the media's talking
point is is that masks are some sort of
full-on guarantee so here is chris cuomo
the other block of wood over at cnn
saying that trump wouldn't have needed
to quarantine if he and his staff wore
masks all the time
the president may have to self
quarantine and uh
that's how it should be that's how it
should if she had had a mask on
yeah and if he had had a mask on the
chance that she was
more about the person at the top
setting the example if the president had
said if he had made it
mandatory in his meetings when he's in
contact with her
to wear a mask then we may not be in
this situation we just needed to pull a
bite
if he had that mask on everywhere nobody
would be making fun of him because he's
the only one who makes cracks about
masks
okay so just to point out here chris
cuomo had this thing was chris cuomo not
masking up right chris cuomo famously
had this thing how'd he get it
his entire family by the way got it and
so
the the sort of celebratory nature of a
lot of the media coverage of this which
is like karma has come to get trump
karma has come to get trump so i'll be
honest with you i think that it will
have some effectiveness
just politically speaking i think it
will have some effectiveness because the
american public
basically breaks down into three groups
it breaks down into a group of people
who say that the virus is
so serious that it's going to kill
everyone that there are people who are
sort of panicked about the virus
to the point where your 28 year old will
say i'm not like this this literally
happened
at a uh at a local school i know a lot
of the parents there
a 28 year old teacher who's in good
health sends an email to the parents
saying i'm i would come to school and
i'd be willing to take a bullet for your
kids at school but i'm not willing to
die
by getting covered from your kids she's
28 and in good health
okay that's very silly so there's one
group of people who are taking this so
seriously that they've actually moved
beyond the data points then there are a
group of people who are taking it so not
seriously they've actually moved beyond
the data points these are people who are
like
70 years old going to rallies in close
contact with other people they have
comorbidities
like that's also not particularly smart
and then there are a bunch of people i
think who are in the middle
who are just kind of cautious about this
and who don't particularly love the
masking
they don't hate them asking they just
are like okay what do i need to do to
get back to my regular life
like i take it about as seriously as i
need to take it and they kind of waver
day to day on how serious this thing is
because people do emotionally tend to
waiver when you see tom hanks has it
then you recover you're like okay maybe
it's not that bad
and then when you see herman cain had it
and he died you're like okay this is
really really bad right it could kill a
lot of people
what happens to trump personally is now
fully tied up
with where we go as a country on covid
which
is kind of stupid but that's how the
human brain works unfortunately the
reason i say it's stupid is because
public policy should not be attached
to anecdotal evidence public policy
should be attached to the best available
data
public policy should be about how you
make the best policy for the greatest
number of people
it should not be about your attitude
about trump or trump's attitude about
masks
or what you take from trump's attitude
about masks you're supposed to be an
independent human being who's able to
make their own analysis
of the issues and of the data that
doesn't excuse people
when they take things too lightly or
when they take things
way too seriously it does mean that you
as
an individual responsible human being
you ought to be looking at the data and
when we make public policy we shouldn't
be basing it on like
did trump had a super serious case or
not super serious case but unfortunately
people are very frequently dumb animals
we are all dumb animals
and we have amygdalas we have fear
centers and so if trump gets this thing
very seriously
then the chances of future lockdowns are
going to be much greater
people are going to skew toward the side
that i think takes it so seriously they
shut down economies again if trump has a
very mild case he's going to be able to
come out and he's going to say listen
the vast majority of people get this are
going to live the vast majority of
people who get this
are fine the vast majority of people who
get this are not going to die i didn't
die and i'm 74
and i'm okay and maybe people will be
like oh okay well you know
that's that's true people tend to
respond to anecdotal evidence in a way
they do not to data and that is just a
flaw
in the human brain it also happens to be
true that when we discuss public policy
on this stuff
it is extremely political so one of the
tweets that was getting
one of the clips that was getting
tweeted out a lot after it came out that
trump has covered
was this clip from earlier in the day
where trump said that the end of the
pandemic is in sight here's what trump
had to say
we have reduced the fatality rate by 85
since just april we are on track to
develop and distribute a vaccine before
the end of the year and maybe
substantially before and i just want to
say that the end of the pandemic
is in sight and next year will be one of
the greatest years in the history of our
country
okay so he said that right he said that
we're the end of the pandemics in sight
we have a vaccine development we're
doing we're doing all sorts of
therapeutics
he's not wrong about that he is not
wrong i think the end of the pandemic
is inside i think scientists would say
the end of the pandemic is in sight
now that timeline may be like first
quarter of 2021 or maybe end of the year
but to pretend that we are closer to the
beginning than we are to the end i think
at this point
is probably you know anti-evidence
people were taking that as evidence
trump isn't taking it seriously
that's not right again public policy is
not about whether trump personally gets
covet just like the death rate on covet
has nothing to do
with what i what personally happens to
me
people's unbelievable misunderstanding
of the data is really a problem
right if i were to get coveted and god
forbid i were to die people would
immediately go well it must be very very
dangerous for people my age it is not
very dangerous for people my age
i just happen to be the unlucky dude who
drew the black marble out of the bag of
1001 marbles 1 000 of which were white
that does not mean that it's super
dangerous for everybody else
in my age cohort but unfortunately
people tend to jump to that so
people ignore the public policy in favor
of the personal
it also happens to be true that many
democrats do not take them asking
particularly seriously
yesterday the democratic pennsylvania
governor and a state rep were caught on
a hot mic
joking about masks being political
theater which is
always a good look by the way it is true
that like when trump has criticized you
know some forms of masculinity
i don't know about you i everybody's now
wearing masks i i live in la at least
for the moment
and everybody in la is wearing masks
many of them are wearing masks
improperly like you actually have to
have a class
in ppe when you are a doctor my wife
took one you actually have to be told
how to don ppe properly if you take a
mask a cloth mask
and you fuzz around with your hands with
it and then you put it in your pocket
and then when you're drinking or eating
and then you put it back on
your face and you've been eating with
your hands right
is the mask still clean no right have
you actually
done anything to prevent the spread of
the disease you may have actually
increased the chance that you gave
yourself the disease by putting your
hands directly on the mask and then
breathing it in
right like there are serious problems
with that that does not mean that you
shouldn't wear a mask it means you
should be careful in how you treat the
mask
but people are conflating the ideal with
the reality and that isn't particularly
true
and here's the thing a lot of democrats
even know this right here is the here's
the pennsylvania democratic governor
joking about mask theater
so wendy i'm going to take i'm going to
take my mask off
i will as well just i'm waiting so that
we can do a little political thing
okay so that it's on camera
okay so there they are joking about you
know i'm gonna take the mask off as soon
as i'm off camera but when i'm on camera
i'm gonna put the mask back on so much
of that so people on the left will say
okay yeah but the virtue signaling is
good because you're signaling the people
that they should wear the mask it's also
possible that the virtue signaling is
overwrought because it's now suggesting
that people should wear masks in some of
the dumbest possible ways
speaking of virtue signaling in the
dumbest possible ways the chicago mayor
lori lightfoot
she actually went to a press conference
dressed as what she called
the roanoke fighter like uh
for for halloween or something this is
the mayor of chicago
dressed as rona fighter my
god this is our politics good times
[Music]
it says rona destroyer on her cave okay
can i just point out that
chicago has had a pretty serious bout of
coronavirus
the chicago coven numbers are are not
particularly good
okay and they've been kind of steady
right now but they are they're slowly
increasing
and there she is posing with a a clorox
poster around her i'm sorry everything
is stupid everything is incredibly
stupid
it just it just is speaking of people
following the science on the left in a
second we're gonna get to california
which has decided on standards for
reopening
and the standards on reopening shall we
say are mildly anti-scientific
when i say mildly anti-scientific i mean
wildly anti-scientific we'll get to that
in just one moment first let us talk
about the
most comfortable sheets and pillows on
the market the most comfortable sheets
and pillows
on the market so my wife was getting
like severe neck and back pain when she
was sleeping because
she was using these pillows that were
basically pancake flat and then
we found my pillow my pillow it's like
it's the best thing
she has had the neck pain alleviated she
and i each have a my pillow because we
used to fight over one of them but now
we have two
we are both sleeping easier it has it
has made
our uh it made us feel better when we
wake up in the morning frankly because
if you sleep with a bad pillow can
really screw up
uh all of your chiropractics mike
lindell he's the inventor of my pillow
and mike's latest steel is on his giza
dream sheets which are made from the
world's best cotton giza the sheets are
also fantastic
see i i spend a lot of time talking
about bedding because frankly i don't
get enough sleep and when i do get to
sleep i want to make sure that it's
extremely comfortable so i use
my pillow sheets i use my pillow pillows
okay and they are just great right now
the giza dream sheets are a two for one
low price plus free shipping with promo
code
daily wire all of the my pillow products
come with a 60 day money back
guarantee just head on over to
mypillow.com and click on the on the
radio listeners square
to check out the two for one low price
on the giza dream sheet plus
free shipping they're also deep
discounts on all other my pillow
products as well
enter promo code dailywire or call
800-651-1148 for these great specials go
check them out right now and her promo
code dailywire call 800-651-1148 for
these fantastic
specials okay in just a second we'll get
to more science of the left again
whenever somebody on the right gets this
thing it's like oh it's a reflection of
the right to anti-scientific viewpoints
if somebody on the left gets it it's
like well we did the best we could
and then we got it it's because we love
science that we got it or because we
love racial justice that we got it
and the gap is pretty stark we'll get to
that in just one moment first
have to mention a few things one we have
another sunday special coming up you
don't want to miss
a great episode this weekend academy
award-winning actor john voight
comes on the show to talk about his
acclaimed acting career his journey to
conservatism
and an inside look into being a
conservative in hollywood head on over
to dailywire.com or listen
on apple podcast spotify or wherever
else you get your podcast here's a
little bit of what it sounded like
end of the war when we pulled out of
vietnam two and a half
million people were killed there's
people trying to cling to helicopters to
hold on to their lives
and i saw that and i was shocked because
they
showed me what communism was
so check that out it is definitely
worthwhile watching
also it is that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
wire member today it's elise
aka wilkie mouse on instagram who knows
how to relax after a long weekend in
this picture
elise has a fire going with some baked
goods in the world's greatest beverage
vessel nearby the caption reads
third fire this weekend means it's
definitely fall in new england spent the
day figuring out how to take apart the
pool
winding up the weekend with black rifle
coffee hot cocoa and my leftist years
tumbler with a treat from oxford baking
company listening to the official ben
shapiro sunday special love the civil
conversations between
people across the political aisle from
each other fantastic glad you're
enjoying the sunday specials they really
are fun we have a great
set of sunday specials coming up for you
in the very near future like a bunch of
them
don't miss this week's show with jon
voight also if you liked our debate
coverage on tuesday night
or even if you didn't you should go join
daily wire right now as an insider or
all-access member if you liked it it'll
be more of the stuff you like if you
didn't like it we'll do better next time
i promise
get 20 off with code debate so you can
watch all of our upcoming debate
coverage live at dailywire.com apple tv
or the roku app
members get our articles ad free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show and
an exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily where members
if you're considering an all access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions you also get not
one but two leftist years tumblr with
your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products
so watch the next debate with us get 20
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign up
today you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now again the differential media
narrative here is that if somebody on
the left gets it it's despite all of
their best efforts if somebody on the
right gets it it's because
they are uniquely morally deserving of
getting it so when
the governor of virginia ralph northam
got it and he is one of the the virtue
signaling masters right he's somebody
who masks up like all the time
then it was like well he did the best he
could and kovac just got him anyway
right he just got it when trump does it
it's like well
you know it's because trump's evil it's
because trump's evil
and it's because he doesn't follow
science here here's the problem so much
of what we're talking about is not
science nobody's talking about science
when they talk about the anecdotal
situation
in which people get this thing how do we
know that this is in science let me
let me let's talk about public policy
for a second right because we talk
politics
i'm far less interested in the
individuals who get coveted on a public
policy level than the public policies we
enact here's what california is doing on
public policy you ready for this
stupidity
so according to the los angeles times
california's larger counties will not be
permitted to reopen their economies
further
unless they reduce coronavirus
infections in the hardest hit places
where the poor
black people latinos and pacific
islanders live
under a new state requirement for
reopening during the pandemic counties
with more than 106 000 residents
must bring infections down in these
places and invest heavily there in
testing
contact racing outreach and providing
means for infected people to isolate
la is sure is one county sure to be
affected along with others in southern
california
the measure is designed to ensure the
test positivity rates in the most
disadvantaged neighborhoods do not
significantly exceed
a county's overall rate a disparity that
has been widespread during the pandemics
so in other words
if there is one section of the city
where nobody has it and there's a
section of the city where a lot of
people have it for a variety of reasons
including that poverty tends to be a
sort of co-morbidity with this thing
people are living in closer quarters
people are not masking as much
there's also significant comorbidity
racial comorbidities
right and this exists by the way not
just in the united states it's in europe
as well
people of color have been dying at a
higher rate of this thing in europe than
they have been than have white people in
europe
and we're still trying to discover the
reasons why some of those reasons may
include other comorbidities that are not
evenly spread across the races like for
example
diabetes or obesity there have been some
possibilities that link this to
for example genetic predisposition to
sickle cell anemia
what this does suggest is that now
they are going to take the section of
the city that has no cases and they're
going to shut it down
out of a misguided sense of equity right
that
now if you have a section of the city of
beverly hills right and beverly hills
has no cases
and then you have south central los
angeles and it has many cases you're
going to shut down both
of them because it is unfair the beverly
hills doesn't have enough cases while
south central has too many cases
is that science in any way you're going
to shut down the entire economy and
deprive people of their livelihoods and
their jobs and by the way
the ability for people in south central
to work because many of those people
work for companies
that are owned by people who live in
beverly hills you're going to shut down
the entire system because of racial
inequalities seriously like the entire
system you're going to shut down
makes perfect sense makes perfect sense
according to the state's acting public
health officer dr erica pan
our entire state has come together to
redouble our efforts to reduce the
devastating toll kova 19 has had on our
latino black and pacific islander
communities
look we should be expending resources
wherever there is a problem regardless
of race and regardless of income level
no question we should be trying to bring
down the positivity rates everywhere but
you're suggesting we now lock down
perfectly healthy areas
because there are other areas that are
perfectly unhealthy and the healthy
areas tend to be whiter and the
unhealthy areas tend to be more minority
so we're gonna punish the white people
for not having enough covet is basically
the idea here which is
totally crazy that's totally crazy and
if it were the reverse
i would be similarly offended because
this is stupid it's like
it's the exact same thing as saying that
everybody who's 20 has to stay home
because a bunch of people who are 80
might die from this thing okay how about
this how about we just don't have people
who are 20 in contact with people who
are 80 for a little while how about that
like there are plenty of ways that you
have to look at how this disease
like does this happen is this following
the science
we hear science science science and then
nobody actually wants to follow the
science
one of the reasons this thing has become
such a mess is because nobody actually
cares
about the science you'll have democrats
joking about masking his political
theater totally fine because they're
good-hearted
you'll have states that are locking down
when they have essentially zero deaths
and the way the media report this stuff
is completely irresponsible earlier this
week nbc news was talking
about manhattan and they said well you
know all of new york state
had 11 deaths yesterday and sure that's
way down from the 800 deaths
that they were experiencing on a daily
basis back in march and april
but it is higher than the six that they
were experiencing just a couple of weeks
ago it's like well
what like those are not equivalent
statements
the difference between 11 and 800 is not
the difference between 6 and 11.
it's it's just the lack of willingness
to discuss the science
is one of the indicators here of how
political this is
that doesn't mean that trump can't have
done better or shouldn't have done
better
his messaging on kovid has been one of
the serious shortcomings of his
presidency it has come back to bite him
in very severe ways so what should trump
do from here this is really one of the
questions
what should trump do from here on in so
here's my suggestion on a political
level the president's only hope at
re-election at this point and put aside
the health level right we're all praying
for the health of the president and his
wife
if something goes wrong it's obviously a
far bigger worry than
the politics of this but we do have a
presidential election coming up in a
month so
if you are president trump what do you
do the answer is you put a camera on you
and you keep it on you basically full
time
right if you are the president of the
united states at this point you should
welcome the american public
into the experience of covet because
people are taking it as a litmus test
for how seriously we should do lockdowns
again people are not looking at the data
people are not looking at the science
people are just following their guts on
this sort of stuff
what trump should do is he should
welcome the cameras in he should say
here i am
at my desk upstairs quarantining there's
my camera guy he's got the mask on
and he is taking a photograph of me and
as you can see i am not dead nor am i
dying
and you should do this basically every
hour on the hour until
he is cleared of covered because
otherwise what's going to happen is
we're going to get the ramped up media
speculation this today
we had ramped up media speculation that
nancy pelosi may end up president of the
united states
mike pence and his wife are negative
he's the sitting vice president of the
united states
like what are you guys even talking
about people were saying what what if we
have to invoke the 25th amendment we're
not there yet guys
okay the president has not been
incapacitated at this point apparently
he has a mild cold
we'll see where it goes if the president
emerges
from this thing in five six four days
and he says listen guys you know the
symptoms are gone i feel fine
this is the vast majority of cases it
might be an actually good reminder to
the american public
again that statistically speaking the
vast vast vast vast vast majority of
people
do not die of this thing i keep
repeating the stats because i think the
stats are way more important than any
anecdotal evidence you bring
anecdotal evidence is just anecdotal
evidence unfortunately again
people tend to follow anecdotal evidence
where they do not follow
the actual evidence which is
too bad i mean too bad for sure
meanwhile
joe biden i mean this this campaign is
falling out exactly as you would want to
for joe biden put aside the covid stuff
right i'm not suggesting that biden is
wishing coverton trump or anything like
that he already
issued what i said earlier in the
program was a very nice statement about
president trump and the first lady but
if you are joe biden
imagine that you're 78 years old that
covet is out there you don't want to be
out in public
and you literally just get to sit in the
basement and everybody leaves you alone
and that's that's your campaign your
campaign is literally just sitting
around watching old episodes of matlock
that's exactly what joe biden is doing
these days and he's able to get away
with it
right joe biden yesterday was finally
pressed in an interview
on court packing he avoided the question
three separate times will it be any blow
back of course not
you dodged chris wallace's question on
that last night about
packing the court so let me ask you do
you support the idea of packing the
court
i'm not dodging the question what i'm
doing is staying focused
do you continue to support leaving the
court at nine
justices what i'm not going to do is
play trump's game
if you're president would you seek to
increase the number of u.s supreme court
nominees
you know that's exactly what they want
me to talk about so we don't talk about
how they're
violating the constitution now
absolutely not absolutely nuts he's been
able to get away
with suggesting that he doesn't have to
answer a question about whether he means
to completely destroy a brand new
government
he's been able to get away with that
because all the focus is on trump you
know maybe for the trump campaign this
is a bit of a blessing in disguise maybe
maybe because he's relegated to you know
not being on the campaign trail
and not doing things take away his
twitter and he'll spend the next 10 days
you know getting healthy and everybody
can actually focus in on the fact that
we have another candidate for president
of the united states who refuses to
denounce antifa
and who has spent the last several weeks
dodging questions as to whether he plans
to pack the supreme court okay meanwhile
the media continue their mission to
apparently be as
crappy at their at their jobs as humanly
possible remember that one time
when the new york times op-ed editor was
fired for the great sin of printing an
op-ed
by tom cotton the senator from arkansas
suggesting that we might want to use
military force to quell insurrectionists
inside major cities
remember that that a bunch of woke
staffers at the new york times said
this is a threat to me it's a threat to
me as a person of color that we would
print this op-ed and so they fired the
op-ed editor
remember this well on thursday the new
york times
published an op ed authored by regina
ipp a hong kong official the paper once
described as beijing's enforcer
calling for hong kong to accept its
relation with china as destiny
it brightens the pages of the new york
times no amount of outcry condemnation
or sanctions over the chinese
government's purported encroachment in
hong kong's affairs will alter the fact
that hong kong was part of china and
that its destiny is intertwined with the
mainland
she said the west tends to glorify
people as defenders of hong kong's
freedoms but they've done great harm to
the city by going against its
constitutional order
and stirring up chaos and disaffection
toward our motherland she is a long time
proponent of course of the chinese
communist party
it resigned in 2003 as hong kong's
secretary of security because she was
quote widely seen as beijing's enforcer
sending police and immigration officers
to perform sometimes politically
controversial raids
so the new york times just ran straight
chinese propaganda
i'm waiting for the woke staffers to to
really get on top of this i need to hear
from the woke staffers
are they upset about the violation of
the rights of hong kong citizens
oh no they have nothing to say about
that there's a giant shock i i just
can't believe it
meanwhile however they are definitely on
top of the main narrative they want to
push
so the narrative that they will not let
go of is that trump is a vicious racist
this cropped up again during the debate
when of course there was this exchange
with chris wallace in which chris
wallace asked him
to to condemn white supremacy
and right-wing militias and he said sure
and then chris wallace said again are
you willing to do that and he said
sure and then biden was like do it and
chris was like do it he's like what do
you want me to condemn
i feel like i just condemned that and
then biden was like the proud boys
who by the way are not a white
supremacist group and then according to
cnn
and then trump says stand by and stand
back and stand by and people took that
to mean that he was somehow encouraging
the proud boys my favorite thing about
this
is the media taking the proud boys so
seriously that the proud boys who are a
troll group okay they are a troll they
are a group of trolls
if you are not familiar with the proud
boys what half of their media is just
trolling
right they're members of the the sort of
alt light slash alt-right
and they're sort of on the border line
between the two and
what they do online is troll so they
took that stand back and stand by slogan
and they put it on shirts
and the media were like would they if
trump had really discouraged them would
they be putting it on shirts
sure they'll put anything on shirts as a
prank i'm also bemused by this
the media's new standard which is that
if someone expresses support for a
politician the politician is now
responsible
for that support so i hope that next
week get to reanalyze the congressional
baseball shooting in which a bernie
sanders supporter literally attempted to
assassinate
republican members of congress over
healthcare
okay but in any case the narrative was
that trump has not condemned white
supremacy as i've been saying over and
over for days now
that's not true even in 2017 when i
thought that he was being deliberately
vague about the alt-right
when i criticized him very heavily for
in his original statement
saying that there were bad people on
many sides on many sides than any
explicit reference to white supremacy he
corrected that the next day
and he explicitly said that the good
people on every side
that the good people did not include
neo-nazis and white supremacists who i
condemn totally right that is a direct
quote from donald trump circa 2017. okay
so
he's not he's since then he's made
multiple statements condemning white
supremacy
like a lot of them and the media refused
to accept the answer they refuse it
they are so committed to the narrative
that trump is a racist that they
literally
we're now playing kathy newman with
jordan peterson if you've never seen
this exchange
kathy newman is a supposed reporter for
the bbc and she's interviewing jordan
peterson
and she says to jordan peterson so
basically you're a sexist and jordan's
like
no he says so what you really mean to
say is you're a sexist and jordan's like
no and she means and she says well by no
i think what you really mean is yes and
jordan's like no
okay well that is the entire media
declaring trump a racist
trump will be like i condemn white
supremacy i condemn it totally like
why won't you condemn white supremacy
it'll be like well no but but i
literally just did that one second ago
like no you didn't we don't believe you
that was one second ago i don't hear you
doing it right now do i that was at
least ones that
one second ago was in the past we are
now in the present will you condemn it
right now
and they'll say sure that's not a
condemnation that happened one second
ago i want to hear you do it right now
okay perfect example of this john
roberts of fox yesterday
he's he's in the press room with kaylee
mcinnady
and he asks her about trump condemning
white supremacy and here's kaylee
mcinning's response
and then i mean this is an insane
exchange it's just an it's crazy it's
just crazy towns
as the person who speaks for the
president does the president
denounce white supremacism and groups
that espouse it
in all their forms this has been
answered yesterday by the president
himself the day before by the president
himself on the debate stage the
president was asked this he said sure
three times yesterday he was point blank
blink asked do you
uh denounce white supremacy and he said
i've always denounced any form
of that i can go back and read for you
in august 2019 and one voice our nation
must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy in august of
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the kkk neo-nazis
white supremacists and other hate groups
i have an entire list of these quotes
that i can go through with you
he is condemned why is currency more
than any president in modern history
just to clear it up this morning can you
naming it make a declarative statement
that you deny that the president
denounces
i just did i mean it's unbelievable
she literally reads him a statement with
a bunch of statements with trump
condemning white supremacy he's like
yeah but will you do it right now and
she's like like i literally just did
that
because what he wants her to do of
course is he wants her to say the
president unequivocally condemns white
supremacy
and and then he'll say well why doesn't
he just say so and she'll be like well
here's a list of quotes
right but why isn't he doing it right
now now's in the present guys
okay then roberts goes on national tv
and then he gets visibly angry at trump
not condemning white supremacy
even though trump literally condemned it
during the debate condemned it the day
after and has condemned it at this point
i believe about 100 times
since charlottesville here is john
roberts getting visibly angry again on
tv to the delight
of the folks over at cnn for all of you
on twitter who are hammering me for
answering that quote for asking that
question i don't care
because it's a question that needs to be
asked and clearly
the president's republican colleagues a
mile away from here
are looking for an answer for it too so
stop deflecting
stop blaming the media
i'm tired of it i'm so tired of it
no nobody no
nobody was deflecting that's not a
deflection
crappy reporter from from vox aaron
rupar said she's dancing around the
question there's no dancing around the
question
they're so interested in ignoring
what biden is doing that they are
willing to just create this narrative of
a whole cloth and by the way let's not
pretend that this isn't
a little bit pre-planned this entire
narrative dean baquette
the executive editor of the new york
times said in the aftermath of
russiagate
that he was deliberately taking staff
and staffing them up on the racism angle
this is in 2019 and then shock of shocks
right before the election
we were going to get six months of
racism discussion who who could have
predicted such a thing
kaylee mackinnon yesterday rightly
pointed out you know you guys have been
paying an awful lot of attention to
trump supposedly not condemning
white supremacists which he has done or
militia groups with which trump again
did yesterday
i noticed that what you're not paying
any attention to is joe biden
legitimately and clearly refusing to
condemn antifa in any way while antifa
has conducted acts of violence in major
american cities across the country for
months on end
she's of course totally right about this
here's kaylee mcinnady
something else lost upon the media is
the absolute turning of a blind eye to
antifa
carrying the water for democrats the
media it apparently agrees with jerry
nadler that antifa violence is a myth
in august senate hearings democrats
refuse to condemn antifa
again no journalistic curiosity here
ideas do not target police officers
ideas do not burn down buildings
ideas do not kill innocent americans
organizations do
and democrats should condemn the
shameful group in the same manner
president trump continues to condemn
i mean she of course is completely
completely right about this she's
completely right about this
okay but that is not going to change
the media's math here it just isn't so
joe biden of course went on this round
yesterday about this
right joe biden showed off the proud
boys logo by the way it was joe biden
who brought up the proud boys in the
first place
right joe biden has given the proud boys
exactly what they want which is in
insane levels of publicity that they
never would have gotten without joe
biden bringing them up
because again the left whole tactic here
when it comes to the riots in america's
major cities
is to somehow swivel this so it's the
fault of you know the white supremacists
and the right wing
and all despite the fact that it's been
riots in major american cities driven
predominantly by the left so here was
joe biden touting proud boys merch
yesterday that was this
good stuff well the proud boys didn't
think that
go online this is the says the proud
boys
that's their symbol right it says stand
back
and stand by nobody
has ever ever ever ever sent that kind
of message in american history nobody
and it's simply wrong okay by the way
joe biden did not call him on it in the
debate because joe biden did not
actually believe that's what trump was
saying
and if we are now going to quote the
trolling statements of members of the
proud boys
as though they are serious analysts of
politics
then we're going to have to wonder
exactly why richard spencer declared
himself a joe biden supporter a little
bit earlier this year
also i was told by the way that donald
trump does not condemn white
supremacists or condemn the proud boys
here he was yesterday condemning the
white supremacists and condemning the
proud boys
i have to say i've said it many times
and let me be clear again i condemn the
kkk
i condemn all white supremacists i
condemn the
proud boys i don't know much about the
proud boys almost nothing but i condemn
that
but he should condemn also antifa
antifa is a horrible group of people
okay so but but apparently he's
unwilling to condemn them
this is this is gonna be the narrative
unless the narrative of course is that
trump deserves the cove
that he has gotten today meanwhile hell
vicious are the media they're they're
going after melania trump too
i mean imagine if anybody had leaked
audio of michelle
obama like private audio michelle obama
during the obama administration you
think the media would have given that
the time of day
or would they have said she's off limits
she's the first lady she wasn't elected
she has nothing to do with anything it
doesn't matter now they're very excited
because an ex-east wing advisor
made audio i mean that's true friendship
is an advisor who makes audio recordings
of you as we learned during the
monica lewinsky days here is a uh here
is
a member of at least their shoes making
recordings of
purported you know politically relevant
activity by the president of the united
states himself
in this particular case melania is the
first lady and now we're getting all
these leaked recordings of melania and
they're supposed to make melania look
bad the media are miscovering them they
don't actually make melania look bad
here here's melania defending the
treatment of immigrant
children and this apparently is supposed
to be very bad here's melania
all these kids that i met they were
they're here in the shelters because
they were they were brought
by it from through coyotes the people or
trafficking
and that's why they put them in jail and
the kids that they go in shelters and
the way they take care of them
it's you know they they even said the
kids they say wow
i will have my own bed i will sleep on
the bed i will have a cabinet for my
clothes
it's so sad to hear it but they have
they didn't have that in their own
country right
okay so um you know that that is
apparently her being unsympathetic
i'm i'm confused as to how that's her
being unsympathetic but
again the media are willing to run with
any anti-trump narrative including
anti-trump narratives that hit melania
for some odd reason
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here on monday
for all of the latest updates
again have everybody who has coveted 19
in your thoughts and prayers
this weekend uh it was hard to imagine
this news cycle could have gotten any
crazier but god apparently decided to
dump out all the crazy in 2020 which
means
i would hope that 2021 might be slightly
calmer since maybe he's exhausted the
supply if not
well i don't know what to tell you i'm
ben shapiro this is the benchmark show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien the
show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.